The history of Japanese manga.
Manga are original Japanese comic books...
...that have a solid niche of followers from all around the world.
Japanese manga creators conform to a particular style of artwork creation...
...developed in the late 19th century.
The storylines of the comic books tackle a broad range of genres...
...such as action, adventure, romance, comedy, drama,...
...science fiction, and fantasy.
Manga plays a huge part in the Japanese publishing industry...
...and isn't showing any signs of slowing down.
With a long history deeply rooted in the rich Japanese art,...
...manga is one of the most fascinating phenomena in Japan and the whole world.
Part of the Otaku nerd culture,...
...these comics have been a major player in the country's publishing industry,...
...creating a robust market, reaching millions of readers of all ages,...
...and influencing a number of works of comic book art...
...in a variety of other nations.
From history to teenage romance to futuristic science fiction...
...and profound themes of life, manga became an important,...
...almost inevitable aspect of Japan's identity and helped spread knowledge...
...and understanding of it across the planet.
Focusing on a creative, unique aesthetic and alluring narratives,...
...they often evolve into anime and even cosplay,...
...remaining constantly popular within their ever growing community and collectors.